Intel's new cascade like exit CPUs are
going to be great but are they actually
worth it
[Music]
welcome to Horus hobbies so first of all
what even is cascade Lake effects and
when is it going to be coming out while
cascade Lake X is Intel's next
enthusiast platform falling the sky like
egg series and it's going to be coming
out at the end of this year or the
beginning of 2019 so if you are looking
to buy an enthusiast level CPU but how
will these CPUs perform and is it worth
it for you well as for performance Intel
CPUs are well known for their great
overclocking Headroom and good
optimization these CPUs probably won't
have as many PCIe lanes or cash as the
rise in threader for counterparts
however if that is not a problem for you
in these CPUs will still perform awesome
so last generation with skylake X we set
7 CPU screws starting from a 6 core CPU
which was just under four rollers all
the way to the 7 & 8 exe which was an 18
core CPU which cost around $2,000 at
Computex we already saw what is most
likely going to be the new flagship of
this series which was the 28 core 5630
CPU build over there it was actually
overclocked all the way to 5 gigahertz
but as we already know by now it was
with the outrageous cooler and so a much
more reasonable estimate for the
overclocking for a normal person for
that CPU would be in the low for me to
arrange like 4.2 or 4.3 Canaries also
the base model will probably be up to 8
or 10 cores because of the introduction
of hexa core CPUs on to mainstream
platform and the soon upcoming 9900 K
which going to be a mainstream octa-core
processor and we will probably see the
same number of CPU SKUs just with larger
increments in between each of them so
again everyone knows that Intel CPUs
perform great and there's really no
questions about its capabilities even
though in tow was exaggerating them
usually the main issue with Intel CPUs
are their price and with the
introduction of rice and thread Ripper
price has become a key issue for the new
enthusiast series for Intel so how much
will these
your cascade Lake X CPUs cost for Mentos
so with skylake X if you match the core
4 core with shredder perk
then you will find the 70 90 60 X and
1950 X both had 16 cores and 32 threads
however the 1950 X came in at $1,000
while the 79 60 X costed almost $1,700
pricing for both these chips have gotten
a lot better and now you get a 1950 x4
779 dollars and you can get a 70 and 60
x4 $1,400 but even despite this huge
price drop the price disparity between
the two chips is still big as well so
last year when mashed chlorophyll core
the Intel counterpart costed about 70
percent more than the rise in CPU so
based on that what will the 9n exceed or
whatever the flagship CPU of the Cascade
like X series cost the newer 32 core AMD
CPU is expected to come in at $1500 and
this makes sense based on Amy's past
price offerings
so using this 70 percent more than that
price would come out to two thousand
five hundred and fifty dollars so we are
probably looking at a price range of
2500 to 3000 dollars for the 28 core
Intel CPU but I think Intel is trying to
be more competitive and it's learning
from their mistakes so hopefully they
offered for 2500 or even less but
knowing in taupe it may cost up to
$3,000 like last time where the flagship
of the 7 & 8 exe was twice the price of
the 1950 X and once again as you guys
can see until the CPU is going to cost a
lot more than the rise and threader per
CPU while not even performing that much
better in this case it actually has four
or less course and ate less threads so
keeping that all in mind is this series
worth it and should you buy it well in
my opinion if you're looking at one of
the lower level CPU SKUs where the price
difference is much less and so it's much
more digestible then it may be worth it
to go with Intel for the higher clock
speeds but as we move up the line the
price disparity grows at an exponential
rate I really just don't think any of
the top line into enthusiast CPUs will
be worth it for them
Christ especially considering that
thread Ripper will offer more of course
so pretty much the higher clock speed of
the 28 core CPU from int o or pretty
much be identical with the lower clock
speed 32 core CPU from AMD and plus 32
core CPU from AMD will most likely have
more PCIe lanes
not to mention significantly cheaper
also AMD is very good at offering great
discounts and these TPS are going to be
coming out very soon so by the time that
a holiday season of this girl rolls
around the initial hype surrounding
these CPUs will have died down and we
will be able to find these CPUs for
great prices for example last year 1950
X was offered two hundred dollars less
than MSRP just a couple of months after
release so this year I think we just may
be able to find a 29 90 X for $1,300
during Black Friday so overall if you're
looking for a high-level enthusiast CPU
with a lot of course I think that the
best bet for you is to stay with AMD and
buy one of their newest Red River CPUs
on Black Friday or the holiday season so
what do you guys think are you guys
angry that Intel is overpriced and
receive used by so much or are you just
happy that AMD is back in the game make
sure to comment down below what you guys
think because I do it all my comments
I'm curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like together they make you
drop but like and consider subscribing
if you'd like to see more videos just
like this one but until next time this
is Hari and I'll catch you guys on the
next one